Ah jerry tell us what delights
have you in store for us
oh you'll love this i call it
jareoke i'll let you guess what
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
full rick and morty season 5 episode 5 video grab
your bottle of sofa wine there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs and references we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes thankfully we're
getting the second half of the season the rest
of the five episodes full ten without any huge
breaks and careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far if you have
not been watching the episodes i'll number all
these easter eggs as we go along shot by shot
starting with the episode title a morty can feedy
which is a reference to american graffiti george
lucas movie that he made before he made star wars
american graffiti is a movie about teenagers in
their bee plot with morty summer and bruce was a
parody of a lot of high school 80s movies mostly
ferris bueller they also used the whole episode as
a parody on their own rick and jerry team-ups that
they've done before in the show calling the two of
them together the combination the lamest cringiest
thing in any dimension even in hell so the writers
were making fun of themselves as much as they're
making fun of everybody else with all these
jokes and their whole solution to the problem
at the end of the episode is to lean into the
cringe like they use genuine sincerity to power
what basically amounts to a cringe gun to defeat
all the hell demons which are based on cenobites
from the hellraiser movies which was the other big
80s movie franchise that they used to inform a lot
of the design of the episode and the characters
and i also think that this is the first time that
they've physically traveled to hell on the show
we've known that heaven and hell exist in the rick
and morty universe in god for that matter because
we know that the devil is canon from season one
mr needful and if the devil exists that means hell
had to exist in heaven and god by association but
then in the cold open rick is unpacking a box of
occult items that's been on his shelf next to the
time travel stuff box since the beginning of the
show i don't think we've ever seen him take that
occult box off the shelf before he takes out a
whole bunch of freaky looking artifacts that look
like they have all kinds of dangerous uses the
big joke being that he just takes the drinking
cup with them that looks like it's made from
some creatures tiny foot like a hollowed-out tiny
creature foot since it came out of the occult box
we'll assume that it has some magical properties
that were going to help rig during the night
satiate the hell demons desire for pain which
they view as pleasure and there were so many jokes
on that trope and after the episode dan harmon
clarified this like they were very openly mocking
a lot of the logic of the hellraiser movies like
wait a minute if pain gives you pleasure does that
mean the pleasure gives you pain and they just
played that to the nth degree many times in the
episode but the basic premise is that jerry is so
lame that it's painful to people to be around him
and that's what gives these hell demons pleasure
so being around jerry for them is like doing drugs
the other low-key joke here too is how during the
episode beth openly acknowledges how lame jerry
is but how she kind of likes him for being lame
because it's so maddening being around rick all
the time like i want you to be friends with my
stupid husband beth also kind of jumps on the
train of making fun of jerry during the episode 2
kind of showing you how her personality
and sense of humor are just like rick's
which she also gets excited about later when the
demons tell her how rick has been saying how she's
super cool because she's kind of like him there
are more jokes about hordes giving birth but
this time it's actual real horses it's not horse
people that live underground the joke being that
the horses at the racetrack like barry white so
they all just started doing with each other but
then they introduced the whole bruce chutback
storyline the b storyline with summer and morty
so he's the big celebrity guest cameo he was
being played by darren chris the whole joke
being both morty and summer are just desperate
to be popular and they think they can use him to
boost their own standing so this is where it sort
of turns into that high school 80s movie parody
there were a couple different 80s movies they were
parodying with this that were pretty easy to spot
when beth tells them if they teleport the house
throwing a party or something they shouldn't come
back that's a reference to season one during rick
c business when they throw the party accidentally
teleports the entire house to another planet when
she catches squanchy squanching himself in rick's
closet there was also another squanchy reference
later in the episode in the bar that i'll point
out because the bar was just full of easter eggs
all over the place but when morty and summer start
making fun of each other for all the messed
up stuff that they've done summer calls him a
grandpa's boy just because he spent so much time
with rick on adventures and when she says he's
always climbing up into aliens that's a reference
to the many many times morty has either literally
gone up inside an alien or been consumed by one or
has sex with some other type of creature which is
a reference to planeteena or the mermaids from
atlantis there's actually a couple of planetina
references during this episode morty reveals that
summer shampoos her pubes which isn't what i would
call perverted or gross or anything it's just kind
of weird i think the joke here though is just the
smallest most insignificant thing about you will
be used by other high school kids to make fun of
you so it doesn't matter what it is about them
it's just that they don't want anything weird
that they've done to get out summer also admits
that she's just as much of a loser as morty or
at least the other kids at school think of her as
a loser and then farts in his face all the high
school popularity jokes and social politics that
they parody during the episode are hyper specific
even the song dan harmon sings explains the
complicated politics of why bruce is so powerful
to them is a brand new transfer student because
apparently it's all about street cred and the joke
during the song is that no cred is the best cred
because nobody has pinned bruce down to any one
thing or caught him doing something embarrassing
which they do pay off in the post-credits scene
with the pants then we learn the truth about rick
submitting himself to jerry time it's just because
he owes a debt to these hell demons which are
based on cenobites from hellraiser selling them
a bunch of defective flesh hooks which they
also pay off at the end of the episode too
there's a direct reference to the tesseract cube
from the hellraiser movies the puzzle box rick
saying it's an evil cube it'll do most of the work
as long as it tastes blood the character design
for all the demons is pretty funny too like one of
them has a bunch of needles propping his neck up
but they're also injecting some blood or something
into him this one has a video color correction
slate for a face like you use these to help
white balance your footage when you're shooting
rick makes a sesame street reference saying
they're like oscar the grouch with the way they
love suffering because it seems like oscar the
grouch loves being a grouch so much so the whole
idea here is that the cringier and lamer jerry
gets the better it is for them the more energy
they absorb the more pleasure they get there's a
sick smash mouth burn when jerry comes out saying
oh they have the entire smash mouth catalog and
the demons really start to get charged up i also
love the whole premise here too like these ultra
powerful hell demons could probably get anything
that they want but they need to buy common skin
hooks from rick like that's the only place they
could get these skin hooks then morty tries
to win over bruce with interdimensional cable
and this is the second time during season five
that they've teased interdimensional cable
when he turns the tv on it's actually playing the
story train commercial from back in season four
the episode they're in the middle of is olympic
diving with bad swimmers and the reference here
is that in real life the olympics are actually
starting just a little while after this episode
airs but the joke here is that the divers are like
the best divers in the world but they all almost
drown trying to get out of the pool somehow the
game that bruce is playing on his phone is called
classic snake which is actually a mobile game in
real life i didn't take it as a reference to time
travel snakes or snake jazz or anything like
that it's just the joke that he doesn't care
about anything that's happening around him like
his expression barely changes in the episode he
does get really excited by rick's spaceship which
i do think is funny he instantly recognized that
it's made from trash like yes yes that is true it
is definitely made from trash the sofa wine that
summer busts out isn't the same wine from episode
one that alternate dimension aged wine that was
the source of morty's war this is just a random
bottle of wine that's being kept in the sofa
which might belong to beth because you don't
see morty and summer drinking wine that often
but they do polish the bottle off by the end of
the episode when they try to get rick's stuff from
the garage they activate his new defense mechanism
which is a big jurassic park security reference
with a a-a-a security measure the hologram
recording even calls it out saying rick just
watched jurassic park again recently it's awesome
i saw it on cable and he'll freeze their bits in
amber just like jurassic park if they mess with
his stuff when they're trying to take the ship
summer references the events of season 2 saying
do you remember me keep summer safe they also
do the same joke from that episode where the
ship starts sassing her making fun of her they
try to defeat it with a logic problem the same
way that rick also tries to use logic problems
to help them later in the episode when they go to
hell but the ship then tricks them into thinking
that it's taken their bait but really just allows
them to use her so that she can go joyride and do
whatever she wants and just blame anything that
happens on morty and summer so even though the
ship came off is really sinister during season
2 because of all the messed up stuff that it did
after this episode you could actually make the
strong case that his ship rick's ship is kind of
evil it even kind of embraces that at the end of
the episode morty's like wait a minute that's the
lesson you took away from this then they start
playing the oh yeah song as jerry is singing
it over karaoke with their montage and they go
full ferris bueller's day off parody with them
stealing the card just like they stole cameron's
father's car during the movie they do their big
montage of morty and summer tearing it up smashing
mailboxes but it's a mailbox based planet and all
the mailboxes are sentient which they also pay
off later in the post-credits scene poor brews
they travel through a wormhole which seems really
cool but you notice the whole joke here is that
bruce's expression doesn't change like he could
care less about what's happening they do a big
parody on star wars phantom menace pod racing
with them seeing like another pod racing ship
that looks like anakin ship flying around but
the big joke here is that the ship looks like a
bunch of testicles and even the alien pilot's head
looks like a ball sack then as they go back to the
bar you pan around their easter eggs all over the
walls with the signage with a lot of the graffiti
you notice one of the drink specials is a rail
gun there's an ipa bc one of them is i am in grape
pain which is a big bird person call back to the
wubba lubba dub dub reference that was the time
that bird person told morty that that phrase wubba
lubba dub dub means i am in great pain then one
of the other drink specials is high iq which is a
reference to the rick and morty meme about having
a high iq you have to have a high iq to understand
rick and morty episodes there's actually a couple
of those high iq jokes in different places around
the bar too and one in the bathroom there's a joke
that just reads has anyone seen my chalk like
how could the bartender have written this if he
lost his chalk there's a woman sitting behind
them that's wearing a shirt with planetina's
symbol on it like our next big planetino
reference there's a neon sign for foamies
which was the beer that rick was drinking in an
episode recently there's a pendant for squanchy
which is our first big squanchy reference in a
while wonder when we're going to see him again
there's a sign on the weight of the bathroom that
reads kellnecks it tastes like ass then in the
bathroom there's a bunch of graffiti references
another high iq reference you gotta have one
inside the stall it says hail satin because this
person loves fleece apparently there's one that
says no more power ballads i mean a lot of these
are meant to be references to bands or music too
the whole thing with the mu tang is obviously it's
the greek symbol for mu but i'm assuming that mu
tang clan is probably just a cover band for wu
tang there's beryllium zeppelin just another
metal cover band for lead zeppelin like lead and
beryllium or two different kinds of metal there's
even a reference to rick and bird persons band
flesh curtains from back when they were younger
if you remember the picture of them from bird
person's house the reference down here for a good
time call 867-5309 is a reference to the tommy
two-tone song jenny when beth shows up saying that
it only takes like two minutes to birth horses
that's just a call back to rick's horse-person son
being birthed super quickly in last week's episode
like boom there you go he's done goodbye then rick
ship reveals his blackmail plan to morty and
summer and they do another montage of it fishing
for galactus using a tiny solar system as bait the
joke here being that galactus is super powerful
in the marvel universe and consumes planets for
energy so as it starts to take the bait the ship
blows a huge hole in its head killing it but gets
really pissed off because it's apparently not big
enough like it wants to kill something bigger and
when they start to question it the ship makes it
sound like it does stuff like this on the regular
like it says the fun is usually in the kill
like it takes pleasure in killing things like this
then they do the big transformers parody calling
these robots change formers their symbol is kind
of like a mix of the autobot symbol with two of
the fingers making a hang 10 pose which i think is
just part of the whole tahoe ski slope 80s parody
like during the episode they parody a lot of 80s
high school movies like ferris bueller but they
also threw in some 80s ski movie parodies with
the transformers storyline south park also did a
similar parody on 80s ski movies a long time ago
too they remind you that rickship is also kind
of a transformer because it transforms so much it
has so many different weapons and hidden functions
and it's not wrong when it calls itself the most
powerful ship in the universe they make a bunch of
jokes about the ship losing its virginity
i don't even know how that would go down
morty reminds us that he is not a virgin and
thankfully he has not tried to have sex with a
doorknob i guess if you're going by the logic that
they used during the episode that all objects are
capable of virginity then you could say that morty
probably lost his virginity to the female robot
during raising gazorbazorp when it starts burning
all them after he gets outed as a regular ship
that's a reference to the movie carrie which is a
high school horror movie about a girl with special
powers that goes crazy when everyone else in the
school makes fun of her when they go back to the
rick and jerry storyline and jerry tries to make
fun of the demon it makes a direct reference to
the hellraiser movies saying no one raises hell
at my expense and then when they start to kill
the other patrons in the horror music track starts
playing cut with the scenes of rick's ship killing
all the change formers it sounds kind of like the
music from the omen movies when damien is doing
evil stuff or using his powers and if you listen
to the lyrics of this song it actually basically
calls that out it just says evil things are
happening when evil things are happening on screen
when rick says you never follow hell demons
to a second location that's just a generic
reference about terrible bar crawl parties like
things always get worse when you go to the second
and third bar during the night only this time
they're literally going to hell you notice when
beth and rick show up in their hellraiser cosplay
the looking outfits behind them is actually a big
back to the future easter egg there's a gravestone
that reads emmett brown and the date of death is
1885 which is from back to the future two in three
rick and morty was also created as doc and marty a
parody of the back to the future movies with doc
brown and marty rick's outfit is just a marlin
somehow stuck through his midsection and later you
can actually see right through his chest so i'm
assuming he used some kind of portal tech to do
this but he's replaced so many parts of his body
he has so many mechanical parts that this actually
isn't that big a deal for him to have a giant hole
through himself beth just has a bunch of darts
in her face and she also kind of reveals that
she's the one who created the costumes then this
is when they really take that joke about pleasure
paying logic to the extreme like to the nth degree
tricking the doorman into allowing them in despite
the fact that the demons wanted rick to come there
anyway like the whole idea was they would lure him
there so they could feed off the rick jerry cringe
combo and like i said the whole thing about them
together being the lamest thing in any universe
that'll be like sweet candy to the hell demons
is just a joke on the show itself them making
fun of themselves for doing these rick and jerry
type of team-ups they escape because of rick's
faulty hooks that they set up at the beginning
of the episode the whole reason why he got himself
into this predicament in the first place he makes
an adams family reference about their situation
because they're just this macabre looking family
everything's just gone really dark but they're
playing it in a really funny way then we go back
to morty summer and bruce and when the officer is
reading their rap sheet of all the charges to them
he references that they had kalaxian crystals
on them which is another reference to that same
rixie business episode where they accidentally
teleported the house which was referenced at the
beginning of the episode there was also a weird
alison hannigan joke in a reference to the movie
upgrade which is actually a really cool movie
that was what they were going for with the ship
hijacking the woman's body with the implant if
you haven't seen the movie upgrade it's basically
a computer an ai trying to implant itself in a
human then this whole part of the episode with
the ship trying to throw bruce under the bus
and morty and some are kind of coming to terms
with what's going on it's just meant to be a
big parody on the moral messages that you get
tacked on to the end of a lot of these 80s teen
movies but then doubling down on how hardcore the
ship is she just winds up blowing that woman up so
they can escape this whole episode in general was
probably the biggest episode for rick's ship ever
like they did so much character development for
the personality of the ship you could actually
do an entire spin-off show just with his ship
and just from a technical perspective the
animation here is amazing then back in hell
rick creates his cringe-powered gun based on
their logic their twisted logic referencing the
joke about how lame jerry's utter sincerity is all
the time then pays off the joke about the two of
them hanging out being the lamest thing ever by
being sincere himself saying that he really does
like jerry when they take out that last demon
and it says could this be the end of mousetrap
nipples i believe that's meant to be a parody of a
famous old movie line from the movie little caesar
in 1931. the simpsons did the same thing a long
time ago too with a zombie shakespeare joke jerry
also scores another win at the end of the episode
when he figures out how to operate the hellraiser
tesseract cube really easily rick's ship reveals
that rick can smell adventure in showers herself
they also then imply somehow that jerry's fart
smells like adventure because it throws rick off
then when morty turns inter-dimensional cable
back on there's a commercial playing for a hot
sauce that's so hot that it burns a hole in the
table watch out for that they don't make any
comments about their crazy outfits they just kind
of deflect when a human skull falls on the table
and jerry punches up the joke by saying oh no
it's a baby skull which is obviously way way worse
then they set up the whole post credit scene
with bruce kind of giving them the brush off like
you know what i'm gonna have to wait to see how
popular you are with all the other kids before i
decide whether or not to be friends with you which
undercuts the entire journey that they went on in
the episode after which they consoled themselves
by finishing off the sofa wine from earlier in
the episode then during the post-credits scene
all the other high school kids make fun of bruce
because they find out he wore the same pants two
days in a row which i think also itself is meant
to point out how lame all the high school kids
are here like that's the dumbest thing ever to
make fun of someone for so they want to say that
all the people here in this moment are all really
dumb dan harmon sings another parody song in
pouring salt in the wound the mailbox people
from the mailbox planet come to retaliate
giving him the same treatment but instead
of pummeling him with baseball bats they're using
all those giant metal flags that are on mailboxes
but if you spotted any other big easter eggs in
the episode that i didn't talk about during the
video just write them below in the comments
overall i feel like it was a better episode
than last week's episode which was kind of
all over the place but my full rick and morty
season 5 episode 6 video will post next monday
just like normal there's going to be a bunch
of stuff coming up this week so make sure you
have alerts enabled so you don't miss anything
congratulations ft the cartoon you're the giveaway
winner from my last big rick and morty video
please email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details everyone click here
for all my loki episode 6 finale videos and click
here for all my rick and morty season 5 episodes
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!